[Music]
hello and welcome back to the road to
2000
tonight on the road i am taking you
through a slightly more beginner focus
lecture
not complete beginner beginner there's
definitely stuff to learn for club level
players
as well but the topic tonight is about
how to actually quote unquote improve
your pieces
and what that means and to
discover that we're going to look at a
few games from alexander alekhine who
was really a master at improving his
pieces it's what helped him become
world champion and we'll see how at his
level back in the 1920s
and i think into the 30s a little bit uh
we'll see how alekhine managed to
improve his pieces and then outplay his
opponents
thanks to his uh beautiful wonderful
useful pieces so let's jump into it here
we have a game
between alekhine against nimsovich and
it is from
this game i believe that we get the term
alekhine's gun
or you know alekhine's really powerful
battery
and so let's see what happened here we
had e4
e6 d4 d5 knight c3
bishop b4 e5 we have a french defense
c5 and now the move bishop d2 which is
not as common these days
generally a3 is a main move here but
bishop d2 definitely still fine
we had this followed by knight e7
and now knight b5 is an attempt to get
at some nasty squares here
bishop takes d2 check to solve the
tension between bishops
queen takes d2 castles to step
out of knight d6 check we have
c3 to support the center b6
f4 bishop a6
knight f3 and queen d7 and let's pause a
bit here
i absolutely zoomed through the
opening for maybe some of the more
beginner level players out there
a lot of that might have not made the
utmost
sense to you at first glance and that's
okay
don't worry about it a lot of it was
white
grabbed a lot of central space early so
then white has to make a lot of pawn
moves in order to support the central
space and to justify
having it around black in the meanwhile
managed to trade off these
dark squared bishops and then did this
slightly strange looking maneuver
with his light squared bishop to get uh
well to solve the problem
of having a french bishop of course the
light squared bishop of the french stuck
behind the pawn chain
he brought it out behind uh brought it
outside the pawn chain by bringing it
out to a6
and he delayed developing this knight so
that this bishop would be a little bit
more defended
in the meantime white uh had to move
this knight out of the way
so he could support the center a bit
more and we saw some traits
but none of that's super important here
not the focus of the lecture tonight
uh in the meantime black has made a
threat to the knight
so white defends it with a4 we have
knight b to c6
and now alekhine plays this interesting
move b4
so why do you think alekhine plays
b4 in this position what was the point
of b4
let's start here why b4 for white
first of all what does it do and second
of all why does alekhine
even want to do it that's a lot of pawn
moves that is a lot of pawn moves
but it was all for white to
support this big center that he's
created
yeah chess king is exactly right it's
forcing black
to either open the c file or
sort of permanently kill his bishop uh
what do i mean by that well of course we
open a file when we remove all the pawns
from
it and so b4 increases the tension on
the c5 pawn now the c5 pawn is attacked
twice
there's really no comfortable way for
black to deal with this
if he does nothing for example play
something like
knights or something like rook c8
for example uh white could actually
consider
taking on c5 he doesn't necessarily have
to but there's really no reason
for whitetail for black to let this sit
he could play the move c4 but like i
said this
now sort of kills off this bishop
forever and white would be happy to jump
in here
uh not only is black sort of ruining his
bishop by making it look at its own
pawn now forever but it's also removing
a lot of the pressure
that black had on white's center so in a
sense
b4 leaves black with only one choice and
that choice
is to open the c file by capturing on
either b4 d4
and now when white recaptures the c file
is open
so why does alakine do this
what's the purpose why open the c file
why
why is that good for white
and this question is a little bit more
important than
the actual mechanics of the move b4
right like it might be difficult to see
why b4 forces black to open the c file
but the point of the lecture tonight is
to get at the heart of why alkyne even
wants the c file open
and that's sort of the thing that you
can take away and
use in slightly lower level games not
necessarily these specific methods for
opening files
but why do you even want an open file if
you have the white pieces here
so we have a lot of good responses in
the chat
but at the core of it the deep deep down
it's because he needs to improve his
major pieces
right if you look at this position you
have two rooks and a queen
and none of them are really doing much
right it's tough to see
how this rook is ever going to play uh
meaning sure it looks great on a1 you
know it's
not going to come under any pressure it
can move around a bit
but it's not going to ever invade the
enemy territory it's never going to make
threats to the enemy pieces and so
uh in chess a very common goal
in fact i would say the most important
goal
in all middle game early middle game
positions is to find a way to make your
pieces useful
and so rooks and queens are very very
useful on open files
why is that well once the pawns are out
of the way
if the rooks ever gets to
uh move forward into enemy territory
because there are no pawns blocking it
then all of a sudden they can start
moving horizontally as well
and attack the enemy pieces sort of from
behind where they're
vulnerable where the pawns are
vulnerable on the seventh rank
so white opens the c file in order to
improve the rooks
aiming to get them into the enemy camp
by
use of this openc file and now what some
people in the chat are saying
is well white opens the c file
because he can use it like this but not
only that
but black can't really use it and that's
going to be
a really really important feature as
well a lot of times in chess
you'll see one open file on the board
and so both players
are well aware of the fact that rooks
are good on the open file because they
invade
so you'll see both sides bring their
rooks over and they'll both
contest this file and at the end of the
day neither side can really get an
advantage from it because both sides
can use the file to their advantage but
we'll see here as some people in the
chat are saying
black has some issues actually using the
c
file effectively and we'll see why that
is
so black first off plays the move bishop
b7
which does look a little bit
counter-intuitive right he brought this
bishop out to a6 and now he brings it
back to b7
so why does he do that well let's say
he takes on b5 right then
all of a sudden what should white play
in
this position we're going to see a
second method
of activating the rooks
great wolf ass doesn't matter if black
takes on d4 or b4 not really
white should capture back with the pawn
either way but black takes on b4 because
why allow white even to consider taking
back on d4 with the knight it's not a
good move in this case but no reason to
give him the option
so yeah we see a takes b5 and a takes b5
would be great
for white first off this knight would
have to move out of the way
perhaps back to d8 and now we'll see the
second type of uh
of way to sort of activate a rook we
talked about
on the open file white can threaten to
bring the rook in to the seventh rank
and we'll see a little bit more of that
a little bit later on tonight but a rook
on a1
is what's on uh what's known as a half
open file
where white no longer has a pawn but
black does and this is another great way
to activate the rooks you don't
necessarily
threaten to come into the seventh rank
or anything the rooks are very powerful
there of course
but here the main threat is the fact
that this rook is just
always going to be staring at this enemy
pawn
and white can even bring the other rook
in to back it up by doubling the rooks
and attacking this pawn even more
thoroughly so
don't get locked in to the idea of the
rook absolutely
having to go to the the wide open file
sometimes it's just as useful to use
your rooks
to target something in a half open file
is usually a great way to do
that just finding a purpose for the
pieces
okay so instead in the game bishop back
to b7
because this bishop was never going to
take this knight because the half open a
file
would be to white's advantage now we do
see this knight jump in
to d6 this is a really great square for
the knights
but we're focusing on the major pieces
obviously alakine is improving the
knight with this move as well putting it
on what's known as an
outpost but let's continue
the move f5 comes from black and black
plays this f5 move
to sort of prevent white from getting
anything accomplished
on the king's side of the board now
black or sorry white actually chooses
the move a5 which is
an attempt to once again try and open up
this a
file or potentially open up the b file
as well
in some cases black plays the move
knight to c8
and the point of this move is that if
you take on b6 black
can take this knight first and foremost
he's just trying to evict this knight
so white has to deal with the threat to
his knight
and he just captures this bishop on b7
we see queen takes b7 and then alekhine
makes a really interesting decision
he knows that he's going to be able to
use the c
file advantageously so rather than do
something like take on b6
when maybe after a takes b6 black can
try and contest the a
file as well he just plays the move a6
and what this move does is after queen
f7 it ensures that the c file is going
to be the only
relevant open file on the board
and now the only thing left to do for
white is to bring the pieces over
so that he can use it
so now we finally see alekhine do
something with this bishop he brings it
out to b5 and you might be thinking
well why did he wait so so long to
develop
this bishop well the reason is
one of the biggest lies i think we're
told as beginner chess players
as we're sort of newer at the game is
that developing your pieces means
getting them
off the back rank and that's not
necessarily the case
in my opinion a better definition is
developing your pieces
means putting them somewhere where
they're useful
right and so up until this moment there
was no more
useful square for this bishop than f1
right we could have brought it out to e2
or d3 but the fact of the matter is
bringing the bishop out to those squares
did not develop the bishop
any more than it already is it still
would only really
be serving to protect the squares on
this diagonal
e2 and d3 doesn't really give it any
sort of advantageous
benefit but now coming out to b5 the
bishop has a very nice benefit
of pressuring this knight on c6
with that in mind we see black play
knight 8 to e7 to defend the knight
and white castles ready to bring this
other rook into the game
now black goes ahead and plays the move
h6
and so of course those of you at home
what should alakine
do next how should he improve his
position here
great wolf asks so we were lied to when
we were learning chess and yes you were
told a great many lies
but sometimes they're useful lies when
you're a super beginner player
it's a lot easier to understand some
basic slightly incorrect concepts
than all of the nuances and you don't
need to understand all of the nuances
all the time so some lies are useful
so yeah everybody knows in the chat you
should bring the pieces
to the open file chess is all about
improving your pieces
so we already know what our purpose is
for these rooks
we don't need to waste time doing things
on the king's side something like
h3 trying to do this we don't need to
waste time moving around this night
because we don't really know where we
want to put it
we know where we want to put the rooks
so let's solve that problem immediately
okay so rook f to c1 and black responds
in kind with rook f to c8
and now the next part of this game
is pretty interesting right so black is
contesting us here
on the c file so what can we do well we
can't break through immediately right
there's no way to get this rook
into the position but what we can do is
start utilizing our other pieces
like our other rook and our queen and
the way to do that
is to double the rooks and in fact in
this case
we'll see alakine goes even a step
further than that
and this is uh this creates what's known
as a battery in chess so rick c2 is
white's turn
and now black might want to try
something like rook c7 but we'll see it
doesn't help him too much
instead he goes queen eight first to
defend the knight more like this and
after rook ac1
we create a battery so a battery can be
made with the rooks
or with uh the queen and a bishop some
diagonal moving pieces or the queen
and the rooks as well as we'll see and
so what a battery is
is when two pieces are sort of stacked
up like this that move in the same
direction so the rooks of course
both can move up the board and when
they're stacked
it means that the rook in the front is
going to have
at least one defender no matter where it
moves on this c
file the pieces are battering
down the c file if you will creating a
battering ram
with the battery okay
and now at this point i will go ahead
and say the black's position
is completely hopeless black is just
totally
busted here uh perhaps here
black's only try might have been to play
the move
knight d8 and this would have allowed
uh white to sort of take over the c file
in a way that you might expect so rook a
to c1
makes a ton of sense here you want to
create this battery still and now black
could try and contest the file with rick
takes c2
rick takes c2 and now if rook c8
trying to contest the file again we'll
see that it is in fact white who wins
control of the file
with the move queen c1 to sort of cap it
off
now black of course would be unable to
contest here because there's no defender
of the c7 square
so 97 would be forced and then white
gets to invade
with the queen and while uh i'm sure to
many of you this automatically just
looks devastating of course white is
just completely crushing here
to some of you it might seem like so
what's the big deal right white gets to
move his queen up the board why is that
so
important well the major pieces are
absolute powerhouses
if they can get sort of behind the enemy
pawns as we see here
and this problem is sort of uh
exacerbated
by the fact that black specie pieces are
so uncoordinated these
knights are doing a really bad job of
keeping this queen
at bay this knight on d8 for example is
hanging
if black tries queen f8 to defend it now
this pawn on a7 will drop
and we start to see that this is
possible because white has invaded with
the queen
just to continue the story queen takes
b6 a7 a8
would be following and white would win
in this manner so this is what happens
if black tries to step out of this
pressure on the c
file with the knight white can
automatically just take
over the entire file sort of without
any trouble instead though queen e8
and now of course white plays rook a to
c1 black plays
rook a to b8 and so we have this sort of
locked position now right we have white
with his doubled rooks
on the c file we have this very
uncomfortable pin
for black and black is sort of in a spot
where he can't
do anything active but for the moment
it's not so clear how white is going to
break through
uh just to state the obvious here
we don't have enough forces to capture
on c6
black is defending them just enough
so what can white do to increase the
pressure here
to utilize even more of his pieces
that's what improving your pieces means
it means using them
for a useful purpose what can we do
what can we do
is today more like a road to 1500 manny
it is a
long road to 2000 and a lot of these
ideas we'll see
are useful to players of a higher level
than 1500 as well
as we continue after all it's aaron
nimsovich that alekhine is playing here
certainly no panzer and if so these
if these principles could get nims of or
could get alkyne by
against nimsovich they might help you as
a 18 1900.
so yeah you guys have the right idea the
first move is the sort of strange
looking rook c3
although i've somehow messed things up
okay uh rook c3 would have been great
immediately alkyne in the actual game
uh sort of took his time with things uh
highlighting the fact that black cannot
really improve his position so he played
queen e3
and now black plays rook c7 to try and
double up here himself we have rook c3
now
queen c queen d7 rook 1 to c2
king f8 and finally queen c1
and this is of course the famous
fabled battery uh that alekhine used to
his advantage in this game
known as alekhine's gun because these
pieces
tripled up on the c file are just too
powerful to handle and now black plays
the move
rook b to c8 adding the last defender
to the knight that he possibly can and
now once again it is actually
white to move and win the game
so i'll present this as a puzzle to you
guys
can you find the winning idea for white
here
so if bishop takes c6 of course then
rook takes c6 would be the response for
black to immediately start challenging
the c
file but everybody has the right idea in
the chat now
of course better than bishop c6 which
would allow rook c6
is bishop a4 and the idea now
is that while black may have thoroughly
defended
the knight on c6 all of his pieces
are currently locked in defense of this
knight
and unfortunately for black if we
just add one more attacker to that
knight then it would have to move out of
the way
what happens if this knight moves out of
the way well we can take
the rook on c7 and thanks to our triple
pieces
that would just be winning a full rook
so if black does nothing then b5 will
come through
and after something like knight b4 we
take on c7
pressure on the queen and just win the
game
so after bishop a4 black tried the sort
of funny
b5 himself making b5 illegal for whites
but now we see bishop takes b5
bishop back to a4 making the same
threats
and black plays the move king to d8
desperately trying to defend this rook
enough times uh and here uh alekhine
plays the move h4 and black was like you
know what
never mind i give up so why
did black resign here well the fact of
the matter is
he is in a very incredible type
of zugzwang every move
for black worsens his position this
knight
is pinned to the queen if white played
the move b5 this is sort of what black
was hoping for he could go knight b4
and on a good day something like this
might happen on a good day this is not
forced by
by white and black would maybe be
surviving
but after the move h4 if black moves the
king
we take on c6 and when sorry if black
moves the king we play
b5 and the rook is undefended if black
moves the knight we play b5 and the rook
is
now underdefended and if we move this
knight
the knight hangs move either the rooks
the knight hangs
and so black simply cannot move any of
his pieces
could try something like g6 but white
will pass
eh5 white will pass next thing you know
you have to move something you just have
to move something
all six of these pieces though would
drop something
were they to move so nimzo simply
resigns
and that's the first game i wanted to go
over for tonight
and it all comes down to this move b4
this is a really great idea to open up
the c file
recognizing that he has a little bit
more space to work with
so he can use his rooks on the open c
file
to win the game and what you take from
this
sort of depends on your level if you're
at a really low beginner level
then the thing to take from this is very
much
definitely rooks belong on open files
and if you're in a position where your
rooks can't get to an open file there's
no open files
a lot of the time it can be a really
great idea to trade off
a pawn or two and that way there are
open files for your rooks to invade
if you're at a slightly higher level you
can look at this as saying
wow we have all this space in the center
how can we actually make something
useful of it
and from b4 we see now
that using this extra space that white
has
uh white can just totally dominate the c
file and that's why the c
file is the file that alakine chooses
to open because he has the extra space
here and is able to sort of dominate
on this side of the board using that
space
and then from there it's just as we saw
he makes sure the a
file doesn't open so there's no counter
play he puts the bishop to b5
and next thing you know it's game over
with the final move h4 okay any
questions about this game
any questions at all
yeah it is a very beautiful ending
position of course where uh black is
just
unable to move unable to move
all right in that case let us move on to
a
second game uh here i want to look
at a game once again featuring the
improvement
of the major pieces the rooks
in this case but also we're going to
talk a little bit more about improving
the knights as well taking a look at how
each of the pieces
work in totally different ways and how
the ways to improve them
also vary pretty dramatically so let's
look at the game
between alekhind and fred deworst yates
uh who was not the worst
he was pretty good at chess okay
please don't stop watching the video
because i said that i apologize i'll
never do anything like that again but
all right we have
a queen's gambit declined in this case
followed by knight c3 bishop e7
bishop g5 castles e3
knight bd7 and once again i'm going
through these
opening moves rather quickly that's not
what i really want to focus on
in this lecture so if these look
confusing to you right now don't worry
too much about it both sides are sort of
just developing their pieces
and white in particular is aiming to put
pressure
on one of the essential squares for
black
we saw rook c1 in the game and this is
down to the fact
that white wants to recapture
on d4 with the bishop if black ever
takes
it and so if white plays bishop d3 here
he would end up taking two turns to do
that with this little stutter step by
his bishop so rick c1 is just a clever
way
to avoid moving the bishop another turn
black does not capture though
instead opting for c6 alekhine now plays
the move queen c2
delaying the movement of this bishop
once again and after rookie 8 he finally
gives up and says okay i want a castle
so i'll develop my bishop
now that white has moved the bishop once
black is happy to take
making white ways to tempo and then he
plays this move knight d5
um okay so knight d5 is an attempt to
trade off one of the black pieces
because black is dealing with a little
bit
less space and that's perfectly fine uh
and now here
alakine plays a pretty interesting move
knight to e4
uh knight to e4 and
from here black actually has a pretty
wide variety of
options one of the simplest is to just
play something like
h6 and force bl force white's hands with
this bishop
well i could also consider taking but
then the downside is
white is making some pretty concrete
threats to the king's side and maybe
black's best move and the reason why
knight e4
isn't played so often is queen a5 check
uh presents black
or presents white a pretty awkward
problem where this king has no good way
to escape this check in fact king f1
might be the best move here
in the game though yates plays a bit
of a screamer in the move f5
so why is f5
a bad move let's talk about it f5 in
this case
very bad move let's talk about why
because it might not be
for the exact reason that some of you in
the chat
suspect so what's wrong with f5 what's
the big idea
this is not the slav this is a
just a qgd i think turned into a
semi-slob eventually
but started as a qgd chess king says
e6 is weak
also manny had a question about the
previous game where it was like why did
nimzo
go for this sort of silly plan of just
defending the night passively
well i showed that one line where if
black had to
if black tried to move the knight out of
the way white invaded on the seventh
rank and was winning
and so probably by the time nimzovich
realized what was happening it was just
a little bit too late
so yeah there are a couple ideas here
weakening in general is a good way to
put it and so there are
two main things that came back to bite
black
in this game for playing the move f5
uh the first one is perhaps the more
obvious we saw some people saying
it weakens the e6 pawn which is true
it's
opposite this bishop and this pawn used
to defend this other pawn and now it
doesn't
uh it turns out in this specific case
that's not the most
relevant weakness though actually black
is defending it well
with his bishop on c8 to follow and this
knight on d5
blocking the diagonal is also not so
easy to make move
out of the way that being said
the other two very important weaknesses
that it makes
are number one to the e5 square how does
it weaken the a5 square
well with the pawn on f7 i can always
push this pawn to f6
and be challenging that e5 square if
anything should happen
and number two believe it or not
i think a very relevant weakness that
often gets overlooked when we talk about
pushing the f pawn
is to the seventh rank believe it or not
this seventh rank that i mentioned
in the previous game we're going to see
is
causing humongous problems for black in
this game
and because this f pawn has moved that's
sort of
one less pawn offering this king shelter
against an attack
on the seventh rank but let's see
how white actually makes use
of these two issues for black in this
game
first and foremost there are some
tactical issues to solve the knight is
attacked and the bishop is attacked
so white takes on e7 with a threat to
the queen first
we see now queen takes e7 and with the
knight under pressure the knight comes
back
to d2 uh okay and now black plays
another bit of a bad move which sort of
solidifies
uh the advantage for white and i think
in fact
just gives white a winning position so
that move that black plays is b5 and of
course now i've highlighted
the two important squares both c5
and e5 are horrendously weak after the
move b5
it's the same thing with the move f7 f5
once again
the pawn could always come to b6 to stop
any threats
of the c5 square and after b5 both of
these squares are horrendously weak
so now the question is okay
we are good you know chess learners we
know about weakening squares and why
that's a bad thing
but how do you actually take advantage
of it when you're playing someone
like the worst yates and he's just
ignoring all of these principles he's
like yeah i don't care i'll weaken these
squares what are you gonna do about it
you have to prove it now so how
can you prove that him weakening these
squares is going to give you an
advantage
how can you prove it
so yeah i mean mateo says you attack it
i guess that's the question isn't it how
do you attack these squares how do you
make them useful
and yeah mendel is getting closer to the
point of me showing this game tonight
these squares function as excellent
night outposts and that's the topic
of this game or of tonight's lecture in
general actually
improving the pieces and the knights
are most often improved when they can
step to squares known as
outposts squares where they are
unassailable
by enemy pawns and where they are
hopefully pretty far
placed into enemy territory where they
can
create threats and create attacking
ideas so
that's sort of the issue here
so for you higher level people
in chat what is white's best move here
white has one best move better than the
rest
you have sort of a decision you can
retreat the bishop on this diagonal
you can retreat the bishop on this
diagonal or you can capture this knight
one of these three moves is better than
the other two
so what do you think higher level people
in chat which one is correct
and yeah most people have the right
answer here so it might be very tempting
to play a move like bishop b3
uh keeping an eye on the weak e6 pawn
and also leaving a pawn on c6 for you to
target
but this is actually much less good for
white
than just capturing this knight the
reason for that
is at a future date
rook ac8 uh
black can very much try to push this
pawn to c5 for example let's say you try
to double
then all of okay this might be a bit of
a mistake let's say you play a3
all of a sudden after c5 black's
position is sort of solving itself
right he's escaping this weakness on c5
is now no longer too much of an issue he
regained control of it by the use of his
pieces and so bishop b3 is not really
the right idea at all however bishop
takes d5
allows black to remove this weakness
from c6
but if you know your stuff you know
that's uh
just because he doesn't have a pawn
weakness on this file
doesn't mean it's not going to be useful
to us and so bishop takes d5
is great for the reason being it's
preventing black from ever
pushing c5 and also it's opening this
file up
for us and thirdly which some of you
mentioned it trades the light squared
bishop
for a knight black has weakened dark
squares
and so this bishop never able to attack
the dark squares
trades itself off for a night which
could potentially someday
uh challenge white's claim
to these dark squares now after castles
white or black plays the move a5
and i would like you guys now to find
the plan
for these nights how do you uh how do
you use these nights
to occupy the outposts what's the best
way to go about it
so yeah the people in the chat are ahead
of me here
you want to go knight b3 and occupy c5
now what's wrong with playing knight e5
immediately
well this would give black a little bit
of a chance to take this knight on e5
and now we're not so happy about
actually taking this back
with a pawn the e5 square was really
weak
and we would love to occupy it with a
piece because from e5 it's a great
central
outpost a knight on e5 would have a ton
of attacking opportunities
for example this knight could jump to
all these great squares
and threaten all these great squares but
with a pawn there
all of a sudden now we can't ever put a
piece on e5 anymore
this is now no longer an outpost
even worse yet we've given up control of
c5 as well
right we had to move this pawn away and
now black is starting to regain control
of a lot of these key squares
so knight b3 is a much better way of
going about it
black plays a4 and now white just jumps
this knight into c5
why is this better well it's better
because after knight c5 removing the
knight from the outpost
we can recapture with a piece rather
than the pawns and this is exactly what
happens in the game
we see takes takes and black plays b4
and so what has white achieved by this
trading of the pieces well
he's removed black's final defender of
the e5
square and now whatever white plays the
move knight e5
this knight is going to be there
basically
forever until white decides to move it
again
and even though this knight is not
targeting any
black material it's a very useful piece
here
because it has the option to jump to any
of these squares
in the black camp and we'll see that
this is how
how white ends up winning the game with
the massive control
that this knight allows him uh in the
game though
alekhine did not immediately play knight
e5 you don't have to play this move
if you did want to play this move it's a
great move you're doing nothing wrong
but you don't have to
instead we see the move rook f to c1
doubling the rooks
as we've seen previously and now after
bishop a6
perhaps trying to jump to c4 we do see
95 and like i said
great attacking prospects for this
knight but it also does a good job
of keeping black out of the c4 square
and now black cannot
actually reasonably challenge the c file
anymore
and the reason for that is because
white's knight
is just too gosh dang powerful
if black did want to play something like
rook
e to c8 to challenge this file
white could potentially just capture and
capture
and the fact of the matter is if you
know a little bit about chess
end games this is more or less a
hopeless one
for uh for black here and in fact white
could even immediately start
picking up some pawns with an idea like
this
the reason this end game is so hopeless
is because white's pawns are all on
light squares
and as uh sorry black's pawns are all on
light squares and black's bishop
is a light-squared bishop as well so
it's unable to really maneuver freely
and is stuck in a purely defensive role
and the fact is there's too many pawns
for this bishop to keep track of here
and like i said with so many different
options for where this knight can go
white is able to make pretty meaningful
threats immediately
so with all that in mind thanks to how
strong this knight is
on e5 this allows white to get an even
bigger advantage
with the rooks because black is unable
to trade the rooks here
so instead we see the move rook e to b8
white plays the move f3 white in this
position can absolutely take as much
time as he needs
because this knight is uh pretty much
going to be there forever
and now black tries his one shot at
trying to get counter play
of course how should we respond to b3
not with a takes b3 allowing black to
open some files
but the simple move a3 and now the
only open file is this c file and white
is the master of it
in the game black played h6 king f2
king h7 and white gained some extra
space on the king side before continuing
with
h4 we saw the move rook f8
king g3 work back to b8 black is sort of
helpless in this position
and now finally the move rook c7 comes
on the board
uh like i said occupying now the seventh
rank
so we saw weakness number one
come into play by white occupying the
square with the knight improving this
knight to a perfect outpost
and now weakness number two is starting
to be felt the weakness of the seventh
rank thanks to this f pawn moving
now in the game we saw the move bishop
b5
this rook came up to c5 as well bishop
a6
and now after rook um
rook c6 white is threatening the e6 pawn
so we saw the move rookie eights and now
white just improves the king further
with king
f4 king g8 h5
this bishop comes all the way to f1
trying to make some threats
so white just defends the pawn naturally
the bishop jumps back
and now the end is near uh
once doubling on the doubling
okay so in the first game doubling on
the c file was enough for white with the
addition of the queen
and now we can do something even more
powerful
which is doubling on the seventh rank
which is exactly what
uh white goes for here with rook f7 king
age 7
rook c to c7 now we have the same idea
but rather than threatening to invade we
are threatening to
murder this king by putting both of her
rooks on the 7th rank
now black plays the move rook g8
desperately trying to defend
and once again uh for you higher level
players
out there see if you can find the
tactical
finish that uh blue yates out of the
water here
white to move and win in this position
of course
any move is winning here but there is a
very very beautiful
nice finish to find
this position is the worst
i agree
i promise not to make that joke anymore
i'm not very good at keeping my promises
why not rook a to c8 after rook f7
that's a good question let's jump back
really quick
rook f7 why not rook eight okay well
this bishop was uh
unfortunately placed it would uh it
would get captured
but as some people in the chat are
saying knight
to d7 is a fantastic move here
and the point now is that we have
actually made a threat of knight f6
check when we would be able to capture a
rook
uh what happens if king
h8 though well then of course we can
play this move
knight f6 anyways takes would lead
to checkmate in one and if something
like rook fades
well then we can just do this i guess i
guess this is good enough
uh and now white to move and win after
rook f8
white to move and win
you sacrificed a pawn a knight so
white to move and win how do you do it
and yeah king e5 is the beautiful last
move of this game
uh the point being if the rook comes
back to f8 or the other rook comes to f8
to defend
we have check and mate
and there's really no other square for
this rook to go
and that is the match so alkyne
just destroying yates in this game
uh using those weaknesses that yates
created early on and yeah sometimes
chess is just this easy i don't know
what to tell you guys
so once again the key point i wanted to
make in this game
is how do you improve knights the most
common
best way to improve your knights is to
get them to
really good outposts squares where they
are defended
by pawns and cannot be attacked by enemy
pawns
in this case e5 and c5 and we saw white
make great use of this in this game
and then also managing to improve his
rooks by getting them to the seventh
rank
the most common way of improving rooks
as well and perhaps the best way
of improving rooks is getting them to
the seventh rank behind enemy pawns
where they can apply some pressure
uh okay let's take a look at game
number three now game number three
and this is one where alekhine has the
black pieces
against another big name here we have
ernst greenfeld
who you may know of the grunfeld defense
fame but in this case he had the white
pieces
so no such luck let's take a look at
what happened here
we have d4 knight f6 c4
e6 knight c3 d5 another queen's gambit
declined
bishop g5 bishop e7 white develops the
knight to f3
knight bd7 e3 castles
rook over to c1 sort of identical to the
previous game so far
c6 queen c2 in the last game i think we
saw rookie 8 be played here
in this game alekhine chose a6
white shows the move a3 regarding some
of these dark squares
and now after the move h6 the bishop
drops back to h4
and finally we do see rookie 8 anyways
so almost identical to the previous game
except a few extra moves sort of
included
and now we do finally see bishop d3 come
on the board and this is black's signal
to go ahead
and capture on c4 so we see takes on c4
bishop takes c4 and now black's idea
with including this move
a6 and a3 is that he can immediately
strike back
with the move b5 hitting this bishop
once again
now this bishop always has to make a
tough decision here do you go
this way or this way both moves are
perfectly playable but in the game
grunfeld chose bishop a2 and the idea of
bishop a2
is sort of multi-fold for one
you can
still apply some pressure to this
diagonal sometimes you'll see stuff like
95
and knight takes f7 threats with
pressure here you can also
drop this bishop back to b1 with
everybody's favorite checkmate threat so
bishop a2 was his choice
and now alkyne immediately breaks
through
with c5 we see the move rook d1
and alekhine takes on d4 knight takes d4
and from here i wanted to
ask you guys how do you improve black's
position black has sort of
just navigated the entirety of the
opening here i'm already ready
to call this a middle game
uh he plays the move c5 to get rid of
white's
central advantage which was offering him
some potential outposts
for his knights so c5 is to remove those
we saw rook d won
takes and takes and now the play with
the pawns is
is sort of over in these types of
positions
where it's sort of a symmetrical pawn
structure
uh really the only thing left to do
is to play with the pieces to improve
the pieces and that's kind of terrifying
for a lot of people myself included this
is not a position
i would want against a player of a
higher level than my
than myself and the reason for that is
because it's all about
how well you understand where pieces
belong
and how you can improve them so that's
my question to you here
you have the black pieces against ernst
grunfeld
how do you improve your pieces and what
do we do
so give me first of all
a plan for this queen give me a plan for
this
bishop and then the third piece i'm
going to ask you to find a plan for
is actually this knight on d7 uh
i am willing to say that this knight on
f6 is already pretty good
right already pretty good guard some
squares the bishop on e7
also already pretty good however
these three pieces definitely need some
work
as for the rooks it's a bit more obvious
they should come
either to the d file or the c file
contesting the only open files
but these three pieces they need help so
what to do with these three pieces
tell me in the chat room
okay there's a few ideas and these are
all pretty interesting
it's fun to see what you guys are
thinking about over there
so everybody seems to be in agreement
about this bishop this bishop belongs on
b7
and i definitely would agree with that
the bishop comes to b7 it's a huge
long open diagonal uh it's
sort of where bishops thrive also oops
bad arrows
so everybody agrees this bishop goes to
b7 problem solved
now the queen and the knight people do
seem to have some conflicting ideas
about
a lot of people want to play the move
knight b6 and bring the knight into d5
uh or even c4 although i'm not seeing
that idea quite as much
and i will say this is not my favorite
idea
and the reason for that is i do think
the queen
belongs on the b6 square i think this is
the absolute
best square for the queen
why is that well it could potentially
come to c7
but in these positions where the rooks
are sort of going to dominate the open
files
it sort of doesn't feel good to actually
have your queen
on an open file that much i would much
rather have it be on b6 where it can
still
impact some of these important squares
on the open files but isn't ever going
to have to
move off of that file again also worth
noting
from c7 the queen might be a little bit
susceptible to this bishop kind of
retreating so
i think b6 is the best square for this
queen and as far as how you can come by
to that
uh as far as general rules that can sort
of guide you to where to put your queen
the queen is a bit tougher than most
it's not like a night where you just
put it on an outpost or a rook where you
just put it on an open file
a lot of times when there are a ton of
pieces on the board choosing where the
queen goes is the hardest step
and sort of the process that i follow
the process that led me
to choose the move queen b6 is looking
at
what's the safest square for the queen
we often don't think of the queen as the
piece that needs the most protecting
but with so many pieces on the board
every other piece
is a lower value than the queen and that
means if the queen ever gets attacked by
any piece
it has to move away it really can't be
defended unless it's being attacked by
another queen
and so when it's on a square where it
can be attacked a lot it's gonna have to
move around until eventually it settles
somewhere a little bit safer
and so queen b6 is that safe square for
the queen
that came to mind so that's how i chose
queen b6 finding a safe spot for my
queen
bishop b7 was pretty apparent but that
does leave the problem
of this knight so what are we going to
do
with this knight where can we put it
knight f8 to g6 or knight c5 those are
both options
and yeah there is another idea floating
around in the chat that i'm actually a
huge fan of
and that idea is knight e5 this knight
could potentially come to e5
now why would it ever go to e5 well it's
not an outpost it's not the final
landing square for that knight it's sort
of an intermediary
this knight can come to e5 and then go
where it actually wants to go
on the c4 square so that's it
we have our plan for improving our three
worst pieces
it's time time to go about it and alkyne
wastes absolutely no time
plays the move queen b6 first it's very
important to get the queen
off of the same file as the rook to
avoid any tactics
uh white plays the move bishop b1 making
a threat or two
and black now plays the move bishop b7
uh white castles and notably
if we play the move knight e5 this is
sort of what white is hoping for
you might have to contend with a few
issues with queen h7 i'm not saying that
white is even winning here because i
don't think he is
but there's no reason to allow this so
black leaves the net on d7
for another moment or two he has other
useful things to do like bring his rooks
to the open files
and kafka look at that white put his
rook
on an open c file and is now being
harassed
by a rook so like i said
good to find the safest possible squares
for your queen when there are so many
pieces
on the board white chose to move the
queen over to d2
and now that this threat is sort of gone
alkyne can finally improve this knight
with knight e5
so there you guys go you you guys in the
chat
uh pretty much came up with the exact
same ideas as alakine
in these positions improving your pieces
to the fullest extent
so 95 white did capture on f6 we saw
bishop takes f6
and white found it worthwhile to step
back to c2
black does need to deal with this threat
and he does so by playing the move g6
and white now gets the queen off the
open file once again with the move queen
e2
what was the point of all that by white
well he wanted to induce the move g6
because it sort of softens up these dark
squares around the black king
okay now black improves the knight to c4
and we see the move bishop e4 by
white so now i have
a very very subtle idea all right
so it looks like we've improved our
pieces to the max right maybe you could
argue this rook would be better on d8
maybe you don't even want it on d8
because you don't want to give white the
chance to trade
so i am willing to say it appears as if
we have improved our pieces to the max
but
alekhine is so nuanced
that he finds a way to improve one of
his pieces
even more here and i'll give you a hint
a little bit later on in the next couple
turns we'll see he finds a way to even
improve this night
but it's not this night yet we'll talk
about this night later he finds a way to
improve
uh a different piece even more than it
has already been
improved so what do you guys think
was knight c5 maddie i'm gonna need you
to be
a little bit more precise i think you
might mean knight c4 but you also might
mean knight e5 or you might mean both of
those moves
can you can you specify do you mean
knight c4 or do you mean knight c5
because knight c5 didn't end up getting
played
uh he did mean knight c4 so yeah knight
c4 i think was
uh a good idea regardless of whether or
not this bishop was on a2 or b1
uh notably it it's a good idea because
it's supported by
a piece we might not necessarily want to
play b take c4
sometimes it's not the worst idea to
open the b file as well
but especially with the rook on c8 we
would be very happy to put this knight
on c4 even if the bishop left itself
here
uh okay so some people are saying rook
e7 to double the rooks
and that's not the worst idea either but
i want to show you a very nice idea
alakain plays the move bishop g7 and
this
is the improvement that i was talking
about and maybe you could sort of subtly
improve the rooks like this as well
sometimes though it's better to have
them on the eighth rank just to
provide some defense but bishop g7 is
strictly an improvement
uh the reason for that is on f6 the
bishop
is vulnerable it's undefended it's a
loose piece
and loose pieces drop off as we know
from g7 the bishop is much harder to
attack
and it is defended by the king no more
tactics against the bishop
and this is definitely something that i
would love to see more of
in amateur level games just taking a
piece that's on
an undefended square and moving it
somewhere it's defended or defending it
on that square
it is so helpful in avoiding tactics and
complications
so bishop g7 was the idea and i'm
finally realizing i'm like running out
of time so let's
play a few more moves bishop takes b7
queen takes b7
rooks c1 and now yeah you guys had the
right idea for this knight on c4
it looks great here but by golly
wouldn't it look even better on d3
how can we make that a reality well we
need to make d3 an outpost
so alkyne pushes this pawn up to e4
and now the d3 square will be a home for
the night
he does bring this rook to the open file
and now we see 95 once again and knight
d3
and at this point white is sort of just
busted black is just positionally
crushing this position with all of his
pieces
on optimal squares i'll play through the
last moves rather quickly
we have rick c8 queen c8
f3 and now a final tactical finish for
you guys if you want to try to find
black's winning move here go ahead and
pause now
otherwise here it is rook takes d4 to
end the game
e takes d4 would be met by bishop takes
d4 check
king f1 and knight take knight f2 check
and you have to have to have to take
this guy otherwise this guy comes with
check
and black wins so instead f takes e4
and now knight f4 is the fantastic move
by uh alekhine e takes f4
queen c4 is fantastic queen takes c4
rook digs d1 check queen f1
bishop d4 check and grunfeld resigns
so hopefully you guys enjoyed
these games from alekhine i find them to
be
really instructive not just for
beginners but
especially for beginners right i think
they're useful no matter what level
you're at to look at and to study
but it's really instructive to see
alekhine wins a lot of these games
just by improving his pieces to the
maximum
and just doing a better job of that than
his opponents
hopefully you learned something new
today about improving the pieces
that is it for the road to 2000. be sure
to stick around though if you're
watching live we have the
end game class coming up right after
this right here on the youtube channel
until next time that's all for tonight
thank you so much
my name is caleb denby and i will see
you next time
[Music]
you